what's up reject nation good morning and
good night to wherever
part of the world you're at our one
division episode 4 reaction should be up
tomorrow sometime between 12 to 1
pacific standard time we're going to
shoot it at midnight tonight so you know
it could be a bit of a process but in
the meantime marvel has released an
extended clip for tomorrow's episode
that we just wanted to check out right
now
and then afterwards we're gonna watch a
breakdown video of it theorizing on some
stuff inside of this clip
just to see if any of that comes true
for tomorrow's episode because it could
be a fun game for us anywho let's swing
into action
[Music]
the dimensions are different than they
usually are yeah
what is it sword says right there
that's the voice that's been yelling at
her
it's cause jimmy's back
oh okay oh
i get it yes
what's next darcy
that's cool so we're going to be going
backwards that's what it feels like yeah
because you're seeing the part where
he's shouting wanda wanda can you hear
me and then
this is when monica enters into there
awesome
oh different perspective get some
answers
no wonder they didn't release any
screeners for critics for this one
anywho okay let's watch this quick
breakdown video from our our buddy
warren from cosmic wonder because these
are always fun welcome back to the
cosmic wonder where we talk all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and we just got an
official clip for one division episode 4
coming out tomorrow
or very late tonight if you're going to
join me for my watch party and this
official caller only
if you're going to join warren for his
watch party from the perspective
of sword this confirms that monica rambo
is indeed going to be one of the major
players
in this show randall park is going to be
it with his character jimmy wu that we
saw in ant-man and the wasp and darcy
is back as well now a few key scenes
here are
one it looks like monica rambo can
actually simply
just go through this energy field what
does that
simply go through the energy field
inside of it in any way it more
looks like sort of a camouflage because
if we look
through the energy field everything
looks normal then we go to a scene where
darcy seems to be
examining wanda and vision and we see a
bunch of different pictures of a bunch
of different people on the wall
now all these people are weird and it
looks like new jersey
for sword and this makes sense because
it does appear like sword could simply
just send people
inside of this force field but one thing
this does do is confirm
that sword is not the people responsible
for putting her inside of here because
as we can see they stumble upon this
force field
but this could actually be a major
reveal
in this shot where it shows all of the
different sword people
as you can see sword has their profiles
of everybody and it looks like they also
have
their identifications for them their
licenses this is most likely because
they take them before they
enter this force field this energy field
and they go into the town
but if you notice this does not have
any type of profile
which basically confirms that agnes is
not working for
sword this is even more proof that she
is indeed the witch agatha harkness
and if she is not working for sword who
exactly is she working for
well most likely the demon mephisto and
this pretty
wait oh wait a minute okay first off i
find this
moment really interesting because you
can just
enter i didn't think it's something you
could just enter into
like the fact that monica could just put
her hand through it i thought it was
going to be something more of the case
of
there's a process to getting it in there
i would have thought yeah
to be fair this is a very slight clip
she's she's grazing it with her hand we
don't know what happens if she were to
make me like
run full force into it but yeah it is a
little surprising that there's no
immediate sort of repellent on it or
something yeah
yeah everyone's looks like it's saying
new jersey
here so if west view yeah it says right
here westview new jersey
it's an established city and then they
are people who are part of sword so what
did why would they just
why would they just assume this person's
part is so why don't they just assume
act at this participle well
or or this is just sword paperwork with
official sword letterhead and these are
all just people they have tabs on
yeah that's what i'm thinking yeah that
seems a lot more like could go either
way like these people are actual
residents maybe monica was collecting
the driver's licenses they don't have
any clue who this person is
yeah yeah that would make a lot more
sense as opposed to just a lot of these
random people
who seem to be like oh what am i doing
here because especially if wanda is
you know making this reality herself or
if swords have taken over an actual town
yeah yeah
it would have to then be like one of
those corporate towns where like only
people who work at this company live
here and then that seems like an odd
coincidence
but they just happen to be the sore
people yeah yeah why not an epcot
instead
i think we're right you're wrong warren
yeah warren challenging you
fury fight if she is not working for
sword who exactly is she working for
well most likely the demon mephisto and
this pretty much
all but confirms that she is indeed act
of the harkness and as expected it was
jimmy wu
on the radio asking wanda who is doing
this to you and he's asking that from
outside of the energy field
so as i've been talking about for a few
days now we are going to be getting some
big reveals in episode four
coming in less than 24 hours so final
chance to drop all of your speculation
and theories about episode four
in the comments down below don't forget
to join me and my watch party tonight it
starts at 3 a.m eastern time so be sure
to subscribe and hit the notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and the watch party
don't forget to like the video for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
do it i do always thank you all so much
for watching
all right okay okay yeah this is pretty
cool that uh marvel decided to release
this because
if you go on like at least on social
media i think
majority of people have really been
enjoying wanda vision i've listened to
enough reviews to
conclude that there's like majority of
people have been really been enjoying
the series but a lot of people
are at the point where they're really
itching to get some actual answers to
get some
more of the mystery really unraveled
that like okay i've been enjoying the
whole sitcom bit i would like to kind of
shift gears a little bit more
really establish like what the hell is
actually going on here you know
just just a tad more even though a lot
of us have been theorizing you got to
think about the general audiences too
who don't really dive into this kind of
content and stuff so i think it's pretty
cool that they released this online and
be like no worry guys
we're sidestepping this is the big
episode this is the everyday
let me start to show you how sci-fi all
this is so the
first three we're all mystery this one
we're gonna shift perspectives and this
has to be going back this looks like the
first time she's entering and she just
happened to have the perfect hair to
enter in
that's what seems so fun about the
prospect of this is that yeah maybe we
will see like the development of
how sword came across this and started
to sort of probe and study it in that
real time of the foundation that we just
laid
probably more compressed time because
it's only going to be this one episode
but
and i wonder then how uh you know the
sitcom will fit back into that because i
have to imagine we'll get at least some
kind of 80s thing going on this next
year i know they have other shows to
uncover
they showed the halloween one the
roseanne type we'll see what's going on
we'll see what's going on inside check
it out keep a lookout for a video guys
once you go ahead subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
[Music]